I really don't know I feel like I feel
like it's not a skill as much as as much
as an ability to think critically and
seriously about what's going on around
people and I'm thinking about the the
new generation coming out of
universities currently their computer
skills are already sort of like inherent
and and so older freelancers will need
to continue to keep up with their their
technological skills and ability to work
with the internet and be able to work
electronically in general with their
clients so to speak and I think that's
just a Productivity issue but possibly
skills that would be more relative would
be the ability to seek out work to
create work for themselves to create
their own sort of micro economy for
themselves I feel like that's possibly
something that I've done for myself in
order to maintain a career as a
playwright I don't actually have any
expectation to make money as a
playwright or two until I'm really
really old hopefully you know but so
I've created I've created a day-to-day
existence that it sort of like fits into
a model so it's a rethinking of its
needs based thinking so it's it's
rethinking what my expectations are for
myself and how I would like to exist day
to day and I think that's an important
skill to have of like of being able to
say I I don't want to get on a train
every day and go to work for somebody I
want to work for myself and this is how
I'd like to see my day structured
absolutely I work everywhere it's it's
amazing what we can do now and you know
from from working with an itouch you can
you can do so much work to working on
your laptop it's it's I have my entire
business on a laptop everything's there
all my plays everything with photos of
my children whatever it's it's
completely self-contained and virtual so
I can sit down and do my work anywhere
the existence of the writer space is
interesting because people actually make
that a destination workplace so we have
roughly 160 to 170 members a quarter and
people come and do their work there but
they also do some work at home and do
some work in the coffee shops or
wherever so it's sort of like another
place for them to put in their mix of
locations to do their work so yeah
technology is amazing right now in terms
of wireless technology being readily
available predominantly free and
accessible and it does enable you to do
things anywhere really